warum hast du es dann geschafft und
wodurch aus den armen verhältnissen ich
bin das beste beispiel um zu erreichen
dass es ausnahme ist in deutschland den
aufstieg zu finden ich kam als migrantin
und dann hieß es
das schafft ich habe es geschafft dass
das auch die typische liberalismus
romantik stories so ich habe es
geschafft ich bin selbst mit 100 prozent
gewählt da bleibst verstehen jetzt
erwartet das ja ich hoffe also ich bin
fast ganz was würdest du deine eltern
vorwerfen dass sie kinder bekommen haben
[Musik]
vom tellerwäscher zum millionär das ist
nicht nur der amerikanische traum auch
in deutschland sollen allen alle türen
offen stehen doch in der praxis wächst
in unserem land jedes fünfte kind in
armut auf und was es mit dem millionen
erwachsenen die hartz 4 beziehen
zusätzlich fördern und noch mehr tun
oder zusätzlich fordern und vielleicht
sogar mit strafen drohen sozialstaat
deutschland könnte es bei uns wirklich
alles schaffen
im mietpool bis ende 40 geflüchtet aus
dem iran die unternehmerin sie ist
autorin ich lebe seit über 33 jahren
hier haben zwei erwachsene töchter bin
selbstständig sie ist auch in der cdu
aktiv leider in der falschen partei ich
kam mit 13 jahren alleine nach
deutschland und das land hat mir
ermöglicht dass aus mir passiert
[Musik]
im mietpool ist teil eines formats im
privatfernsehen groß viele fragen um die
frage von ausstieg wie man versucht da
irgendwie zu den deutschen american
dream da irgendwie zu verkaufen der nur
zwei mann träumt ihrem irisch ich in
eine art familie cruise gewirkt ich war
selbst damals bei der
europameisterschaft bechern
flaschensammeln ein bisschen taschengeld
zu haben ich kenne und weiß was armut
ist in deutschland
er hat auch ein buch geschrieben zum
thema kinderarmut und studiert jetzt den
usa
er wird sagen dass wir keinen gerechtes
soziale stadt haben und da muss ich
ihnen widersprechen
jeder der behauptet dass man durch den
biss motivation durch ein bisschen
arbeit durch ein bisschen fleisch den
aufstieg schafft da hat glaube ich so
genau verstanden dass das de facto allem
hat nicht möglich sein muss auch wills
schaffst du es auch täglich
[Musik]
mit des jeremias herzlich willkommen auf
meiner couch
kein wunder dass in guten tag ich muss
sagen ich freue mich wirklich riesig
dass ihr da seid weil ich eben schon als
hier reingekommen seit von beiden sonne
energie gespürt habe dass ich direkt
dachte heute ist dampf drin habt ihr
lust zu streiten mitgebracht ich immer
richtig freue mich ich glaube dass ich
durch und durch streiten das debattieren
kommt man zu guten lösungen zu guten
schlussfolgerung kann es in deutschland
jeder schaffen eure beiden positionen
könnten eigentlich nicht weiter
auseinander sein ich glaube dass wir
eine chance haben da zusammen zu kommen
in einigen punkten jahr aber nicht hin
aber gut man muss ja auch nicht mehr auf
gemeinsamen nenner kommen ich denke auch
dass es meinungsunterschiede geben wird
ich glaube aber auch dass es bestimmt
punkte geben wir nur wenn konsens haben
da bin ich mir sehr sicher aber gerade
wenn es um so system bedenke fragen geht
die sozialen aufstieg in deutschland vor
allem berechtigen legitimieren da werden
uns denke ich schon unterscheiden lassen
ich habe jetzt für euch beide was
vorbereitet um mal zu gucken wo stehen
wir denn hier am anfang unserer kleinen
sitzung und wird euch bitten einmal
aufzustehen um zu helfen
ich will jetzt als erstes klären wo
stehen die beiden eigentlich und denkt
mit einem seil kann man sehr schön klar
machen wer zerrte an wem und vor allem
in welche richtung wo gibt es konflikte
und wo gehen die bayern vielleicht auch
wieder ein stück weit aufeinander zu
was habe ich mitgebracht eine ganze
reihe von aussagen entweder von euch
oder von anderen zu unserem thema heute
und ich möchte jetzt gleich sehen wie
nah seid ihr denn wirklich und vor allem
china bleibt ihr wenn sie ans
eingemachte geht was kommt denn jetzt
auch nur zu der rapper contra car wrap
sich erfolgreich in millionen kinder und
jugendzimmer unter anderem mit dieser
leyen erfolg ist kein glück sondern das
ergebnis von blut schweiß und tränen
ist das eine gute message für junge
menschen in deutschland
ich will von mir aus niemals behaupten
wollen dass ich meinen weg so geschafft
hätte wenn ich nur ein bisschen fleißig
gewesen wäre ich hatte verdammt viel
glück natürlich spielt leisten rolle im
sozialen aufstieg das würde ich gar
nicht bestreiten und hab da auch eine
gewisse übereinstimmung aber erfolg ist
vor allem auch produkt von glück es ist
die schlussfolgerung von eventuell die
richtigen menschen getroffen zu haben im
richtigen moment den richtigen setting
den richtigen institutionen der
versprechend ist erfolg definitiv auch
eine frage für den klub erst mal
auseinander gegangen jetzt hast du glaub
ich ein stück auf ihn zu gemacht was war
da entscheiden im letzten satz war nicht
korrekt ja menschen brauchen auf jeden
fall vorbilder und man sagt ja immer
reichtum und armut kann man verehrten ja
aber trotzdem es gehört auch glück dazu
und der villa ich kann mir auch mit 13
jahren hier alleine ich sprach die
deutsche sprache an ich muss mich hier
integrieren ich musste auch in der
schule ankommen man hat mir viele steine
in den weg gelegt aber ich habe aus den
steinen schöne dinge gebaut also vor
allem eine frage des willens den 100
prozent dem villa tickt da bleiben wir
stehen jetzt erwartet das ja ich will
also ich bin fast ganz ich verstehe
deinen punkt und auch da eine
perspektive doch es ist mir zeitgleich
ein bedürfnis zu sagen dass das auch die
typische liberalismus romantik stories
so ich habe es geschafft ich bin
selfmade und habe bei gehen ganz ganz
viel selbst geworden romantisch
liberalismus oder so was ähnliches hat
hier in den raum geworfenen ja das ist
für mich typisch sozi aussage möchte das
mal so sagen darf in deutschland groß
geworden ich bin weiß groß geworden ich
bin männlich groß geworden ich bin
straight groß geworden ich habe auch
allein aufgrund meines glücks in deutsch
spaß zu haben ganz anders groß geworden
ich kann nicht von mir selbst aussagen
das ist alles nur meine arbeit mein
wille mein schweiß meine tränen sondern
auch die arbeit und die unterstützung
durch von außen bekommen aber er hat
doch auch mit herzblut mit schweiß auch
geschafft armut klebt an dir sie lässt
dich nicht los ich würde sagen
ich nicht so sie ist überhaupt nicht so
es
war so als ein zentraler satz in deinem
buch ist es tatsache dass jedes fünfte
kind in deutschland in armut leben
600.000 langzeitarbeitslosen warum hast
du stand geschafft obwohl doch aus den
armen verhältnissen und ich geh du hast
diese chance gehabt du hast es chance
genutzt und unser staat hat dir geholfen
dass die schon seit ist wenn eltern
hatten auch die chance haben vielleicht
nutzt man kann aus armut draußen du bist
du bist du beste beispiel ich bin das
beste beispiel um zu erreichen dass es
ausnahme ist in deutschland den aufstieg
zu finden die teilweise widersprüchlich
sie sagten alle anderen schaffen lich
ich bin nun beste beispiel das zeichnet
uns aber in einer kann schafft und auch
die anderen auch vor das ja ganz konkret
dass wir jetzt konsequenzen schaffen
müssen sanktionen anstrengung und
eigenleistung in allen bereichen und du
sprichst es schon an und die bestrafen
wenn man nichts tut ich halte von
sanktionen nichts es ist entwürdigend
und das müssen andere gehen aber andere
prinzipien herrschen als angst aber mit
den existenziellen ängsten zu spielen
ich habe ja selber drei
hartz4-empfänger familien als experten
begleitet sechs monate lang und diese
menschen haben vielleicht teilweise noch
nie gearbeitet und möchte ich dann auch
erleben durften wie es ist so arbeiten
vorbilder für ihre kinder zu sein das
heißt sie haben es gelernt in diesem
halben jahr und dann haben sie auch ihre
sichtweise geändert jetzt wir schon
arbeiten sie wie den geld und sind
unabhängig vom staat was ist das für ein
falls also eine verzogene darstellung
vor dem unterstützung wenn da ein
millionär kommt und super erfolgreich
unternehmerinnen und bisschen mentoren
ein bisschen jobs schreiben dann klappt
das oder weg natürlich gab es nicht so
aber ich gab es auch familien die sagten
warum soll ich arbeite hingehen ich
verdiene doch weniger geld als vom hartz
4 und das ist eine sichtweise die
vertrete ich gegenseitig diese menschen
müssen sanktioniert werden weil die
zwingen wie auch zur faulheit
die zwingen wir dazu dass sie sagen
warum soll ich arbeiten brauche ich doch
nicht weil wir es reicht ja vielleicht
mit 446 euro die runden kommen und da
sehe ich dann definitiv viele
stellschrauben werden wir drehen
bisschen oder eventuell langsam zunehmen
was hier sofort klar wird ist das ja mir
ist immer gesagt ich muss ein stück weg
ich nehme abstand das sehe ich ganz
anders und ist sieht es eigentlich auch
sagt die ganze zeit versucht ihn wieder
zu sich zu ziehen ich mag diese übung
mit dem seil deswegen so sehr weil die
ja ganz klar zeigt wir wollen vielleicht
gar nicht so weit auseinander gehen ich
möchte auch gucken auch wenn ich anderer
meinung bin kann ich den anderen doch
wieder zu mir holen sicherlich gibt es
den einen oder anderen der nicht
gewolltes zu arbeiten oder wo der wille
nicht vorhanden ist aber dass zu
reklamieren für 600.000 menschen die in
deutschland langzeitarbeitslos sind
findig zu fraglich und auch für meinen
teil zu kurz fragt mich mal warum dann
eltern es nicht geschafft da meisten wir
hatten bei die aus oder waren sie von
anfang an kranken ein du wirst auch
automatisch kann wenn du dich arbeiten
jetzt diese lebenserfüllung hast du
nicht und durcharbeiten diese
gesellschaftliche diese sozial und es
gibt jedoch auch das gefühl aber unter
den menschen zu sagen auch mal arbeit
sondern auch mal erfülltes leben zu
führen haben das ist schon viel wert wie
machte mit ist einen ganz wichtigen
punkt es gibt es in der psychologie eine
theorie die sagt jeder mensch hat so
drei grundsätzlich angeborene
bedürfnisse autonom wollen wir sein wir
wollen kompetenzen und wir wollen
verbunden sein also meine chefin haben
die lobt und kollegen der mit uns ein
bierchen trinken geht wenn ich meinen
job verliere feld all das weckt drei
grundbedürfnisse sind nicht mehr
befriedigt 1 fällt mir auf dass sein
hängt so langsam ein bisschen durch
obwohl gefühlt noch mehr spannung im
raum ist als und das freut mich dass
seien
aber die unterschiedlichen positionen
sind sehr schön klar geworden ich würde
euch bitten lasst uns zurück auf die
couch gehen und mal gucken was wir
bisher schon haben
[Musik]
ich würde erstmal von euch erleiden
gerne wissen wie sich das jetzt
angefühlt hat hier so viel druck schon
direkt rein zu geben und da war ja
wirklich sprengkraft und ich finde ich
gut
also ich finde sprengkraft in dem
kontext wichtig weil die konversation
und so diese unterhaltung findet nur
wenig statt was ich sehr gut finde dass
wir beide keine theoretiker sind ja dass
wir aus praxis farben gesprächen duos
noch dann familiensituation ich mit
meinen drei familien die ich erlebt habe
und das finde ich hat natürlich ein sehr
guter ansatzpunkt ich glaube der
unterschied auch in unseren meinungen
ergibt sich aus einem ist schon durchaus
signifikant punkt ich sehe das ganze
system ist ich mein ich habe ja darüber
ein buch geschrieben und habe fast mich
damit auch einfach sehr intensiv
politisch und erkenne an dass nicht nur
ein zwei stellschrauben dort helfen
sondern das ökonomische kulturelle
soziale ressourcen de facto existenz
sind wenn man in armut groß wird und
natürlich sind an coaches gut aber das
ist nicht unbedingt der einzige punkt
mentoring und vorbilder da sind sich
beide einig das braucht es unbedingt und
das kann die psychologie nur bestätigen
denn ein vorbild kann mir zeigen was
möglich ist das motiviert natürlich
unglaublich zu sehen auch wenn es nur
einzelne geschichten sind hey ich kann
das schaffen und ich habe bei beiden das
gefühl in diesen komplett persönlichen
geschichten steckt doch unglaublich viel
vorbildfunktion drin wir sind schon
einen riesigen schritt weiter wenn wir
sagen wir könnten über lösungen reden ja
ich möchte erstmal verstehen wo fangen
wir eigentlich an weil dieser debatte
weil ja beide bei punkten völlig grad
eben schon in die eisen gegangen seid wo
die wut hoch kochte bei die hat man sie
gesehen das energische bei dir zum teil
am ziehen am seil wo stehen wir ich
würde gerne mit euch beiden dazu etwas
machen seid ihr noch mal dabei
um zu begreifen wo ich heute stehe lohnt
sich oft ein blick in die vergangenheit
und genau das machen wir jetzt die miete
ist du nimmst am kopfende platz und wir
machen richtig technologie genau das ein
rollentausch du übernimmst jetzt mal
meine rolle als psychologe und ich habe
eine stadt frage mitgebracht damit wir
in deine geschichte voll eintauchen und
danach übernimmst du ihre mias du und
dein zwillingsbruder das hat mich in
deinem buch wirklich massiv bewegt ihr
seid elf jahre als sie es zu hause nicht
mehr aushalten deine mutter hat euch
mehrere stunden lang eingesperrt dein
vater die tür eingetreten und jetzt
triffst du eine folgenschwere
entscheidung und sagst wir müssen hier
weg hier geht selber zum jugendamt und
sagt holt uns da raus kommst dann in ein
sos kinderdorf in kaiserslautern und ich
habe mich gefragt der erste abend als du
deinem bett legt was geht dir durch den
kopf
den ersten tag das war ja für mich hat
er lange kein eigenes zimmer ich habe
zum ersten mal ein eigenes zimmer und
natürlich fühlt man sich sehr
verantwortlich für seine eltern wenn man
das halt auch nicht anders gelernt hat
fragt sich erstmal wie geht es den
eigenen eltern als ich mit dem mit dem
mit dem auto die letzten klamotten
abgeholt haben erstmal mit axt durch sce
geholt habe und es war einfach dieser
gesamte tag war wuchtig an dem morgen
das werde ich nie wieder aber halt da
die große runde der betreuerinnen
sozialpädagoginnen und da war ich halt
mit dem geschehen und in allen tränen
ausgebrochen weil als elfjähriger
kleiner junge bist du dann in so einem
setting das ist schon nicht einfach das
war schon ist perfekt das war schon sehr
sehr fordernd definitiv wie hat er mit
elf jahren sich gefühlig war das
vielleicht so wie du dich mit 13 jahren
allein am flughafen
gefüllt war das so gibt es parallelen
was meinst du warum dein bruder ist
nicht geschafft hatte mein bruder war in
einer unterfinanzierung der definitiv
unterfinanzierten einrichtung als die
meiner hohe fluktuation zahl betreuerin
betreuer möbel waren kaputt meines
achtens kinder unfreundlich und mein
bruder hatte weniger glück als ich viel
weniger glück waren meine eltern schon
immer krank oder ist sie ihr soziales
leben hat sie dann halt potters erkrankt
in depression geführt aufgrund der
biografie von meines vaters war mir
eigentlich klar dass das was er gegeben
hat das beste war dass ergeben konnte
mein vater ist seitdem ich denken kann
depressiv meine mutter hat er auch eine
ganz ganz gewalttätige kindheit erfahren
de facto hatte ich also eltern die mit
sich selbst überfordert waren dafür
können sie nicht es war auch eine
situation die vor allem produkt war von
von armut von ihrer situation
stigmatisiert weggefallen armut ist
verdammt spürbar sismi spürbar und nicht
nur abstraktion dass man bis weniger
geld hat sondern es ist ein dilemma das
jeden tag ein von neuen herausforderung
stellt und wenn du jetzt ganz offen und
ehrlich wärst was würdest du deine
eltern vor wer heute
dass sie kinder bekommen haben das wird
schon vor werden ich glaube dass man
also ich bin sehr dankbar dafür ich bin
dankbar dass ich auf der welt bin aber
es ist halt schwer kinder zu bekommen
man selbst nicht in der funktion der
lage ist kinder bekommen zu können aber
ich bin trotzdem danken da dass ich hier
bin dass ich die erfahrung habe dich mit
deiner haben darf für die erfahren bin
ich so verdammt dankbar und
dementsprechend ist es vielleicht doch
gut aus sagt der welt bin was für eine
aussage oder die finde ich muss man
gerade erst mal sacken lassen dass er
hier zeigt ist ein unfassbarer schmerz
von dem glaube ich hier nochmal klar
wird was das eigentlich bedeutet den zu
durchleben nicht nur für ihn sondern
auch für seinen bruder was er überhaupt
nicht sagt und auch an keiner stelle
meint das wird immer wieder klar ist
dass menschen mit psychischen problemen
wie seine eltern oder leute die wenig
geld haben oder hartz iv empfangen oder
oder oder keine kinder bekommen sollten
darum geht es überhaupt nicht für ihn
geht es um seinen ganz persönlichen
schmerz und wie sich der ist das wird
hier glaube ich ganz klar die miete ist
das geht unter die haut oder wenn man
zuhört definitiv also ich muß ich bin
normalerweise nicht sehr emotional aber
weil die geschichte werde ich muss mich
so gut rollentausch ja du bitte auf die
couch
in meetings es ist 1987 wir sind in
teheran
und es gibt einen bombenalarm in diesem
moment entsteht in deinem kopf die idee
ich muss hier weg und zwar nach
deutschland und von diesem moment wo die
flucht jetzt hier anfängt bis nach
deutschland ist es ein weiter weg aber
der erste tag als du hier bist du in
deutschland ankommst wie fühlst du dich
da
ja ich war will dir dass ich nicht mit
dem boot nach deutschland gekommen bin
sondern mit dem flieger landete dann hat
in frankfurt habe dann meine oma anrufen
die in hamburg gelebt hat gesagt ihr gut
ich rede jetzt hier und musste dann
irgendwie durch füßen und hinten in zug
organisieren und damit ich mit der bahn
nach hamburg gefahren von frankfurt so
und dann hat mein neues kapitel begonnen
wenn man selber keinen krieg erlebt hat
kann man sich gar nicht da hinein
versetzen würde damit identifizieren so
wie ich auch seine armut nicht
nachvollziehen kann als das neue kapitel
begonnen hat und ich musste erst mal 90
des faktischen deutsch gesprochen zu das
gar nicht also dass die leute spaß haben
mit händen und füßen wahnsinn was waren
so deine ersten niederschläge und
repression die du erfahren hast aufgrund
der tatsache dass du nach deutschland
gekommen ist ich wurde gemobbt in der
schule kinder die immer wieder halt
nicht ausgelacht haben auch kummer wie
frech und die spricht trotzdem kein
deutsch und lebt ihr finger weil ich
wollte ja natürlich nie die klasse
wiederholen weil ich immer angst hatte
ich mich wieder so weit ich hatte eine
sehr autoritäre und strenge vater der
mann gesagt hat wenn du es nicht
schaffst dann kommt zurück ich hatte mal
ans und gott wenn ich zurückgehe wieder
kopftuch tragen muss und die krieg
wieder erleben musst ich habe natürlich
schon ein stück mit angst gelebt und ich
muss zurück und aus dem muss was werbe
und du musst studieren und du musst es
schaffen und mein vater mein größter
mentor aus dem iran und immer wieder
gesagt hat muss sich integrieren du
musst da ankommt aus mir aufgefallen
dass einfach dass diese gesamte
stärkeren das wurde mir noch nicht so
klar dass nach so einer existenziellen
angst heraus kommt so was ist wenn ich
nicht leiste und mir geht es da und das
fand ich überraschend mir geht es da
ähnlich eine frage die mir die ganze
zeit ist durch den kopf geht weil gesagt
vor allem der druck auch aufgrund der
situation aufgrund von angst wieder
zurück in den iran eventuell zu kommen
wie bist du mit solchen moment
umgegangen klar in dem moment als ein
14-jähriges mädchen bist du erboste so
sauer auf dein vater sagt sebastian
strengen vater aber wenn ich zurück und
wirklich es hat doch mehr was genutzt
hat die orientierung gegeben kann ich ja
was sich hier unfassbar schön finde ich
noch mal zeigt das wie nah die beiden
sich kommen wenn es um die persönlichen
erfahrungen geht wenn die sich
austauschen und wirklich verstehen
wollen was treibt den anderen eigentlich
um und bei init ist wird mir noch mal
klar dass sie sagt ich habe es doch
geschafft mich durchzuboxen gegen viele
widerstände und da jetzt zu sagen das
war einfach nur glück diese butter las
ich bin ich vom brot nehmen da halte ich
meine fahne hoch und zeigt dass auch
andere und ich finde das steht jedoch
absolut zu und ich wusste als angst klar
angst ist kein wegbegleiter aber
trotzdem finde ich so eine mischung zu
sagen ich habe da ein bisschen druck und
ich muss mein ziel erreichen und mein
vater war zu dem zeitpunkt leer gesagt
natürlich schaffst du so viele menschen
haben es geschafft und schau doch mal
zurück was du alles schafft das und
viele menschen bleiben liegen und das
werfe ich auch viele menschen vor sagt
gib dich nicht auf stehe auf und kämpfe
als auch für das was sie auch zu stellen
was du erreichen kannst und man merkt
dass ihr bei euch gefühlt wieder fast
auf dem schoß sitzt und ich würde das
zum anlass nehmen dass wir vielleicht
einmal den stuhl weg tun und zusammen
zurück auf die couch kommen
man versteht auf einmal so was sind die
persönlichen absichtlich was die motive
geprägt über die wir reden da hatte ich
aber einen riesen lesen gast aktiven
stärke in der form wüsste ich nicht ob
ich die gehabt hätte wie ging es dir als
ihm zugehört hast ja schon sehr
emotional und die geschichte hat mich
schon sehr berührt
ich finde dass er einfach super vorbild
sein kann für kinder die aus diesen
verhältnissen kommen also ich glaube in
meine sendung hätte ich am liebsten nach
meiner seite
was kannst du denn animiertes geschichte
für dich besonders ergreifend wo du
sagst da fühle ich mich richtig rein
einsatz ganz zu anfang das du aus angst
gehandelt hass aus angst zurück nach den
iran zu gehen wie du mit der angst
umgehst allein nach deutschland kommen
nicht die sprache zu sprechen jeden tag
das ist das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen habe so einen riesen respekt
vor dieser lebensleistung erlässt der
blick in die vergangenheit in die
persönlichen geschichten ist das eine
aber wir stehen ja vor einer
gesellschaftlichen mammut-aufgabe und in
der psychologie geht es natürlich auch
darum den fokus zu bewahren und deswegen
brechen wir das jetzt einmal runter ich
möchte von beiden den jeweils größten
vorwurf an den anderen in nur einem satz
hören was er jetzt macht ist euren
größten vorwurf an den anderen in einem
satz auf dieses schild
jeremia
system itis macht und ihr für diesen
satz vor
[Musik]
ich hab so ein buch
tut mir den gefallen tauscht jetzt
einmal die schilder und schaut was zu
meinen schriftliches nimmt das von
jeremias und jetzt ist es ein gefallen
stellte ich einmal die hin und ließ den
vorwurf an dich vor im netz ist
schlussfolgert sehr viel nein zu viel
auf basis des eigenen individuellen
aufstiegs und einzelnen familien die sie
nicht
repräsentiert reuth hat
da stecken ja zwei aussagen dann einmal
mittels achtet zu sehr auf den eigenen
individuellen erfolg das ist deine
geschichte und dann zusätzlich die
familien die du nennst die sind eben
nicht repräsentativ einzelfälle du
kannst nur diese drei oder vier familien
davon spricht und ich glaube da war der
knackpunkt wo wir uns nicht einig
geworden sind diese familien sind zwar
einzelfälle jeder ist einzelfall über
diese familie gibt es und davon gibt es
jede menge du ich habe ja nicht nur
diese drei familien kennengelernt ich
habe vorher noch weitere zehn 15 20
familien kennt die genauso auch tickern
die auch ihre einstellung so es die
schlussfolgerungen die du triffst dass
du quasi annimmst 1 2 punkte ein
bisschen mantrailer bisschen lebenslauf
bearbeiten bisschen unterstützen
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen monetär
ist gut das ist sehr sehr sehr herunter
gebrochen das sind so viele faktoren die
da eine rolle spielt aber ändern um
einen punkt 16 ringen da muss man auch
anfangen und das meiner meinung nach der
anfangs ist es ist problematisch wenn
man anfängt ohne wirklich genau zu
wissen wie die dinge miteinander in
relation stehen um das mal einfach zu
sagen genau du sagst mieters hat ihre
einzelfall erfahrung aus ihrer eigenen
geschichte und den einzelfällen die duh
beobachtet hast aber das große ganze hat
sie nicht im blick und macht deswegen
falsche schlussfolgerung sie mir ja gut
ich habe hinter dem privatfernsehen 20
leute gesehen aber du darfst nie
vergessen ist aus einer individuellen
erfahrung und du bist einfach super
willen stark und du bist
unternehmerinnen und du bist das tun
gewöhnt und und dunja
projiziert deine eigene wesentlichkeit
schon irgendwo fast auf andere und das
nachdem entsprechen arbeitslos also die
nicht kontrahent sein können ich sehe es
anders aber gut dafür sind wir ja da um
zu diskutieren unsere meinung zu äußern
hast du jetzt die chance dass wir deinen
vorführen tauscht doch bitte einmal
wunderbar vor was dein größter vorwurf
an ihn ist ich bin sehr gespannt
jeremias armut kann man nicht leicht
bekämpfen und bleibt an einem kleben
wenn du denkst du bist lebenslang armen
und du bleibst da hängen wenn du bleibst
in diesem loch und du kommst nie raus
aus diesem loch das ist schon ein sehr
trauriges bild ich kam als migrantin und
dann hieß es unten die krankt das schaff
ich habe es geschafft und darum kann es
eine 14 jährige die als flüchtlinge
komisch schaffen warum weil du es
geschafft das kann dein nachbar aus dem
hochhaus nicht schaffe ich stehe voll
und ganz neu ist dass ich nicht mehr in
armut lebt mittlerweile gut geht dass
ich auch in der zukunft sicher ein sehr
gutes einkommen haben werte dazu steht
in vollem maße aber ich weiß zeitgleich
dass das nicht die realität ist für ganz
ganz viele menschen in der de facto
armut lebt und auch kleben bleiben wird
ich will nicht dass jemand mal meinen
erfahrungen abspricht und das hatte ich
so das gefühl sie es getan hat in dem
moment da möchte ich mal vom pranger
befreien du stehst ganz nah mit dem
rücken zur wand und ich würde sagen
kommen auch wieder auf die couch weil
wir haben ja jetzt
eigentlich wunderschön zwei seiten hier
auch sehr klar aufgemacht in den beiden
schildern das wird fantastisch klaren
armut kann man leicht bekämpfen das ist
deine aussage du wirfst ihm vor dass er
sagt man kann sie nicht leicht bekämpfen
vielleicht war es denn für dich zu sagen
ich bin jetzt da wo ich stehe das ist
sehr sehr schwer
natürlich aber es geht gleich mal ich
damit es ist möglich das zu schaffen und
ja weil ich vielleicht auch der starke
wille hatte und es kommen auch diesem
thema tolle wundervolle vorbilder und
mentoren anne seith hatte wenn du
menschen hatten sich motive die das den
weg aufzeigen
dann kannst du so schaffe und wie viele
kann man auch lernen weil du dann auch
natürlich auch positive ergebnisse
daraus etc sowie hartz 4 empfänger die
arbeiten gehen und sie auch ich kann
durch arbeit und gehen und mein neues
china ich kann meine kinder ein
selbstständiges leben einfach anbieten
mein kind kann auf die klassenfahrt mit
reis mein kind darf sein geburtstag fall
mein kind darf auch amos und auch mal
spielzeug bestehen obwohl er kein
geburtstag hat solche dinge müssen sie
erstmal erfahre hier muss ich mich kurz
einklinken weil man natürlich gerne sagt
lieber langzeitarbeitsloser bleibt
motiviert guck mal links und rechts was
sonst noch in deinem leben geht studien
zeigen aber dass wenn man menschen mit
wenig geld vor ein geldproblem stellt
das die in intelligenztests viel
schlechter abschneiden als menschen ohne
geldsorgen und zwar nicht weil sie
dümmer sind sondern weil ihr hirn
natürlich die ganze zeit einem
unglaublichen überlebensmodus ist wo er
habe ich genug geld für essen wie
bezahle ich die kleidung oder die
nächste rechnung das ist ein permanenter
stress und da sind eben weniger
ressourcen frei um mal links und rechts
zu gucken oder motiviert zu bleiben ich
möchte eine sache feststellen bis
hierhin lege ich euch auf die couch
bitte euch mal in die eigenen
geschichten einzusteigen fallen die
nachher so wörter wie respekt ich fühle
mich so ein wahnsinn holt mich ab
unfassbar krasse geschichte toll toll
toll von beiden seiten fangen wir wieder
an über die sachthemen zu sprechen muss
ich was von streit sprechen weil es
sofort wieder heiß her ging ich würde
aber jetzt gerne sagen wir werden
praktisch und kreisen jetzt zusammen in
unser aller zukunft macht ihr mal mit
einmal umbauen werde ich dabei
wir machen eine agenda 20.30 also der
blick in die zukunft was braucht dieses
land in den nächsten jahren und das will
ich von den beiden ganz konkret wissen
[Musik]
du wirst die bundeskanzlerin frisch
gewählt und es ist deine erste
bundespressekonferenz gestellt die
agenda 20.30 vor auf der couch sitzt die
kritische presse und deine mission ist
uns jetzt von einem konkreten
maßnahmenplan von ideen gerne auch
vision für die zukunft zu überzeugen
unter dem titel sozialstaat deutschland
hier können wir es alle schaffen einen
wunderschönen und tag meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
deutschland ist ein sozialer staat aber
ist mir ist als bundeskanzlerin bewusst
dass wir viele stellschrauben an denen
mussten und ich wünsche mir 2030 dass
wir weniger kind haben ich würde mir
wünschen dass ein kulturpass für kinder
geben würde dass die kinder kostenlos
zum beispiel fußballverein besuchen oder
schwimmbäder oder musik und da sollten
wir ansetzen
sie sind die erste bundeskanzlerin mit
wie sie sagen migrations vordergrund und
haben eine bewegte geschichte in der sie
auch geschrieben haben naja wenn die
leute dann eben nichts machen dann
müssen wir sie bestrafen können wir das
konkret machen wie sollten leute in
deutschland bestraft werden die vom
sozialstaat leben wir haben ja genug
jobs sie haben genug stellen diese
menschen nach arbeiten können und wenn
sie sich weigern aus welchen gründen
auch immer dass man dann auch die
sanktioniert dass welchem maß das die
dann auch teilweise ihre gehälter
gekürzt bekommen oder ihre gelder die
sie monatlich bekommen konkret wie viel
prozent
50 prozent also von 418 hören dazu 46
auf 206 da bin ich der meinung dass
diese druck schon was bewegt meine
eltern wurden ja selbst wenn alles
funktioniert und ich weiß dass das sehr
schwer über die runden zu kommen und das
ist stress das ist absolute premiere und
das wünscht keine keiner familie glauben
sie dass ein leben mit 250 euro wenn man
50 prozent das ist ein würdiges leben
ist nein ist es nicht
definitiv nicht aber deshalb müssen wir
in der politik punkte oder bzw optionen
und möglichkeiten anbieten damit diese
menschen auch ein würdevolles leben
führen können also man ist bringt nichts
davon dass wir von hartz 4 empfänger
also wissen wir dass wir in vier geldern
bezahle ich sage leben einfach
lebenslang dein leben nein da müssen
andere ansätze hier dass hier gerade ein
ganz großer und wichtiger moment weil
need is klar sagt ich kürzer bis die
würde der menschen angegriffen ist und
jeremias sagt dann ja aber ohne würde
wie soll ich motiviert sein und mich
wieder hochkämpfen können ich glaube
dass es im miet ist nicht darum geht
irgendwelche menschen fertig zu machen
im gegenteil sie hat ja den anspruch
durch das runterdrücken im prinzip eine
motivation zu schaffen sich wieder zu
befreien und das sind eben zwei völlig
unterschiedliche wege die eigentlich das
selbe ziel wollen der kalender der
bundeskanzlerin ist war extrem voll und
damit würde ich sagen seid ihr bereit
für den rollentausch noch mal gerne
[Musik]
sehr geehrte pressevertreter innen stark
dass sie heute zu kanzleramt erschienen
sind um ihnen heute in diesem raum die
agenda 2030 vorzustellen als
sozialdemokrat und warum sagt der
sozialdemokrat wir haben aus unseren
fehlern von damals gelernt und
verstanden dass mit sanktionen und mit
anderen maßnahmen wie viel weniger
erreicht haben als wir es angenommen
haben vor vielen jahren einer der
forderung ist dass wir ein
kinder-grundeinkommen etablieren das
ressourcen genutzt wird und ein sozialer
mobilitätsticket zu sichern das
ressourcen das in das junge menschen
frei sich entfalten können dass wir
menschen die in hartz 4 leben die alg 2
beziehen dass wir den mehrbedarf wie von
sozialverbänden gefordert von etwa 200
euro decken und damit lebens würde damit
neue motivation und damit neuen geist
die sie dann dazu bewegt besseren und
sichereren weg in arbeitsmarkt zu finden
was machen sie wenn diese menschen sich
weiter zu ihre fortbildung die sie
anbieten wollen wir menschen die einfach
nicht hingehen nach sicherlich ist es
erstmal so dass das auf ein bruchteil
aller arbeitslosen der fall ist und ich
bin realist genug um zu verstehen dass
es diese menschen immer geben wird ich
appelliere an die moral und auch an das
selbstverständnis mit den menschen in
deutschland leben und das ist in der
regel zu arbeiten und jene die es nicht
tun die werden haltungssystem so
gehalten sein weil sie immer existieren
werden
warum man diesen menschen fördern
eigentlich locken weil armut zum einen
lebens- und würde bedeutet es ist ein
würdeloses leben es geht darum dass wir
lebens wird es schaffen und damit so
viel mehr kultivieren können aber wie
würden sie sich denn als als
steuerzahler fühlen wenn sie sagen ich
bezahl und arbeiten lebenslänglich und
unbezahlte immer und und es gibt
menschen die meinen wir mal schmarotzer
in lehrende auge dass die davon auch
leben und sorgten nicht gehen ich
arbeite ich war mir ein schönes bequemes
liebe frau praß vertretern ich höre
konstant ein narrativ heraus das werfe
ich nämlich unser staat vor dass diese
menschen eigentlich mentorin und
vorbilder brauchen diese menschen
brauchen eher alltagsnutzen die auch sie
ein vorstellungsgespräch zu gehen und
ihr müsst uns beigebracht bekommen wie
ein kleines kind es geht nicht nur um
beim besten willen und menschen die eine
arbeitslosigkeit dem zumal die
arbeitslose situation ist vergessen mit
dem kontext sehr gerne sich auch auf das
kind überträgt und wir haben als
repräsentatives institut nämlich im
bundestag der regierung die
verantwortung uns auch um die kinder zu
kümmern denn dies in unsere zukunft die
werden für uns die renten bezahlen und
die geht auch eine agenda 20.30 zentral
herr bundeskanzler wird der presse
vertretung vielen dank an dieser stelle
und ich würde sagen wenn ihr beide mir
noch einmal elf kam auf die zielgerade
oder
wird hier noch mal klar was das
eigentlich hat für eine achterbahnfahrt
ist die wir durchmachen oder da gibt es
momente wo die beiden sich halb auf dem
schoß sitzen sich eigentlich schon total
einig umarmen größten respekt
füreinander haben und dann fliegen
plötzlich wieder die fetzen da liegt für
mich der wert im streiten weil ich
glaube das schafft klarheit ihr habt
heute ganz unterschiedliche vorwürfe
euch auch entgegengebracht einmal mehr
sie als punchline zusammengefasst könnt
ihr dem anderen vielleicht aus diesem
vorwurf jetzt mal einen wunsch
formulieren ich wünsche mir dass du
hast
ich wünsche mir dass du weiterhin so
tapfer und standhaft bleibt
und einfach dein weg macht und dass du
auch mal vielleicht deine stimme in der
politik mal gibt und in der politik was
bewegt das würde ich mir für dich
wünschen die auf den weg geben was ich
mir wünsche von dir ist dass du die idee
von arbeitslosigkeit aber auch die idee
von leistung und
differenziert weil es kann häufig vor
das ist halt immer so schwarz und weiß
war so entweder gibt es das ein oder das
gibt es nicht und aber es gibt andere
variablen die arbeitspotenzial und
leistung erheblich beeinflussen können
und ich wünsche mir von dir dass du das
auch in deinen aussagen und auch in
deinen gedanken mit ein baustein
handshake zum schluss
ja ich bin unglaublich dankbar wirklich
dass ihr mit lee gestritten habt dass
sie für uns gestritten haben weil ihr
habt zwei standpunkte klar gemacht die
glaube ich in unserer gesellschaft immer
wieder aufeinander stoßen und das so
unterschiedlich einmal auf der sachebene
immer und immer wieder und dann aber
auch mit eurem ganz persönlichen ganz
praktischen erfahrung ich wünsche euch
bei ein wirklich von herzen weiter alles
gute ich bin der meinung dass wir beide
eigentlich wirklich ein gemeinsames ziel
verfolgen
nur auf andere art und weise ja ich
glaube aber das hat eben doch in puncto
wie armut angegangen werden muss dass
wir uns da sehr fundamental
unterscheiden ich bin vielleicht die
härtere der ist vielleicht zu sehr
sozial ich habe riesen respekt vor ihrer
leistung in ihrem ersten super vorbild
sein für diese arbeit so wie ich super
vorbild bin vielleicht für viele anderen
erkrankten die nach deutschland gekommen
bin sicher dass wir auch in der zukunft
legen jemand kontakt stehen werden weil
man voneinander dort sehr viel lernen
kann abseits von unterschieden die immer
noch existieren so das war es schon
wieder mit der folge auf der couch wenn
du lust hast dass dein lieblings
gastmahl hier bei mir auf der couch
platz nimmt dann verraten jedoch wenig
einladen soll unten in den kommentaren
wenn du mir noch einen daumen hoch da
lässt freue ich mich nicht nur sondern
weiß auch dass diese folge gefallen hat
und vielleicht sogar diesen kanal
abonnieren dann hast einen großen
vorteil denn du weißt als erstes
bescheid wenn es eine neue folge gibt
ich würde sagen alles drei lohnt sich
und dann schon jetzt recht herzlich
dafür bis dahin